Microsoft has a given up on trying to
innovate this is a usually a terrible
sign for companies we've seen countless
examples of juggernauts being toppled
over due to a lack of innovation from
Nokia and the Xerox the Blockbuster and
Yahoo
but this doesn't seem to be hurting
Microsoft in fact at this point they
haven't been innovating for quite some
time Microsoft is the only Tech Giant
that hasn't created a revolutionary
product within the past 10 to 20 years
Apple has the iPhone Google has Chrome
Amazon has AWS Tesla has electric
self-driving cars and even meta is
trying with the metaverse but what about
Microsoft Microsoft is still really only
known for two products windows and
Microsoft Office and it's been nearly 40
years since Windows was released and
over 30 years since office was released
for those of you commenting that they
created chat jbt they didn't create that
they bought it and this is really the
secret behind their success over the
past 15 years they've been trying to buy
themselves to the top historically
speaking though on Innovative companies
buying Innovative companies doesn't
usually work out likely the most notable
example of this in recent history is GE
back in the late 2000s they did
everything from jet engine manufacturing
and financing to producing appliances
and pumping gas but eventually this
became way too much to handle and the GE
would end up shrinking their investments
from 781 billion dollars to 164 billion
dollars
they've even spun off into three
different companies to try to lower the
burden so little to say you can't just
buy yourself to the top but Microsoft
seems to be the exception as they've
been doing better than ever in the past
five years alone the revenue has doubled
their net income has tripled and their
stock well their stock has grown at 10x
within the past 10 years for perspective
that's the same amount that Apple has
grown and they've had the mobile
Revolution on their side so has a
Microsoft cracked the code to eternal
life or are they going to end up like GE
thank you
taking a look back the reality is that
Microsoft has never been Innovative with
their products the key to their success
has always been a brilliant business
strategies into marketing as opposed to
actually creating the next big thing
this is true for even windows and office
Windows was ripped off from the Mac
which was ripped off from Xerox so the
product itself wasn't all that
Innovative but what was Innovative was
Microsoft's go to market strategy
instead of limiting their software to a
specific piece of Hardware they made it
compatible with basically everything not
only did they make Windows compatible
with everything they also made Windows
accessible to everyone by actively
encouraging piracy and if you don't
believe me here's Bill Gates on the
topic sort of as long as they're going
to steal it we want them to steal ours
I sort of sort of get addicted and then
we somehow figure out how to how to
collect sometime in the next uh
in the next decade so you know it's a
great great place to be involved in and
it was a lot of fun which was I guess
the the key as you can see the key to
Microsoft's early success was simply
extraordinary Market penetration while
not everyone was paying off the bat this
strategy gave Microsoft unbelievable
Market control which they were
eventually able to monetize by licensing
to PC makers corporations universities
and governments
this was really phase one of Microsoft's
rise they were able to successfully
substitute Market penetration for
Innovation moving on to phase two we
would see Microsoft substitute Market
domination for Innovation the first
notable example of this was Internet
Explorer Microsoft saw the explosive
success of the internet back in the
early 90s with AOL and Netscape and they
decided they wanted a piece of the pie
so in 1995 Microsoft would go ahead and
launch IE but again there was nothing
particularly special about ie it was
just there one of the male browser with
an even less inspiring name I mean it
was literally named Internet Explorer at
least there is no confusion about what
it does I guess but none of this
mattered because Microsoft once again
had an effective strategy to get the
product to people the strategy was to
Simply bundle in IE with Windows sure
people could go out then download
whatever browser they wanted after they
buy the computer but back in the late
1990s people were just then getting
their first computers so most people had
to know baseline or prior expectations
everything was new to them so they might
as well stick with the browser that's
already there this would lead to ie's
market share rising to 95 by 2003 and a
slew of antitrust lawsuits but that's a
whole other story The takeaway here is
that IE wasn't successful because it was
Innovative aii was successful because
Microsoft was able to leverage their
domination with Windows Microsoft would
use this same strategy on a few more
products throughout the late 90s and the
early 2000s MSN search for example was
decently popular because it was pushed
by IE which was pushed by Windows the
same thing could be said about Hotmail
and MSN Messenger and basically all of
Microsoft's other products during this
time period but if you read the news at
the time you would see headlines that
yes Microsoft was a monopoly but also
that they were the most Innovative tech
company in the world and let's just say
Microsoft would let this go to their
head
[Music]
by the end of the 1990s Microsoft had
become the world's largest company and
there is anonymous with tech fun fact
Microsoft is the only top 10 company
from the year 2000 that's still a top 10
company today but maintaining this level
of success was by no means an easy feat
in fact the next 10 years would be the
decade of failure for Microsoft as they
would try to innovate and their
inability to innovate would really shine
through
the first notable example of this came
in 2006 with the Microsoft Zune most of
you have probably never even heard about
the Zune and the main reason for this
was that it was such a massive flop the
Zune was essentially Microsoft's answer
to the iPod but there were a lot of
fundamental issues with the Zuna
starting with the timing for starters
the Zune came out five years after the
original iPod meaning that the iPod was
already the go-to product for most
people so Microsoft was fighting an
uphill battle from day one but that
doesn't necessarily have to be a bad
thing plenty of successful products came
out super late like Chrome Gmail and
zoom but the reason that these products
were able to take over was because they
were categorically better than the
competition the same could not be said
about the Zune the Zune was by no means
a bad product in fact users liked it
just as much as the iPod and it costed
the same as the iPod but this was also
the biggest problem if it's identical to
the iPod who would buy it over the iPod
which was already the popular thing well
the answer is no one and a Microsoft
would cancel the Zune just a few years
later Microsoft should have learned from
this and approached smartphones from a
different strategy but Microsoft would
go ahead and make a fool of themselves
not much later
I mean just listen to former Microsoft
CEO Steve ballmer's reaction at the
iPhone
five hundred dollars fully subsidized
with a plan I said that is the most
expensive phone in the world and it
doesn't appeal to business customers
because it doesn't have a keyboard which
makes it not a very good email machine
now to his credit he did clarify that it
might sell really well but if that's the
case you probably shouldn't be laughing
at it it may sell very well or not I you
know we have our strategy we've got
great Windows mobile devices in the
market today we you can get a Motorola Q
phone now for 99 it's a very capable
machine instead you should be looking at
why it might sell well who will be
buying a product and how you can get a
piece of the pie Microsoft was in the
perfect position to become the windows
of the smartphone world but instead they
would let Google take this spot in the
meantime Microsoft would sit around for
three years and to come out with the
windows phone in 2010 the worst part
though was the OS the reason the iPhone
was so successful was not because it was
a small computer but because it was a
reimagined small computer every single
application interaction and a gesture
were reimagined to work on a smaller
screen with fingers instead of a mouse
you could say that Apple was indeed
innovating with the windows phone on the
other hand we basically got a beta
version of Windows 8 on a smaller screen
unsurprisingly the Windows phone
wouldn't not only be a humiliating
failure but also an expensive one but
unlike with the Zune Microsoft would
actually learn from the Windows phone
and let's just say they've turned things
around big time
usually companies have quite an ego when
it comes to acknowledging or acquiring a
competitor they usually want to do
everything themselves this was very much
the case with Microsoft as well instead
of working with AOL and Netscape
Microsoft decided to compete against
them instead of working with the iPod
and iPhone Microsoft decided to compete
against Apple but all of this would
change in early 2014 when Satya Nadella
took over the company Satya was very
different from his peer CEOs most tech
CEOs are world class in specific Fields
Tim Cook for example is a world-class at
supply chain and operations
similarly Sunder piche is the technical
genius behind a chrome Satya on the
other hand wasn't an expert in any one
field nor did he go to IIT in India or
Stanford and Harvard this is by no means
to say that Satya was incompetent but
the biggest characteristic he brought to
the table was not a technical skill
rather it was humility he had the
humility to accept that younger newer
companies were simply doing things
better and instead of trying to resist
like his predecessors he was going to
embrace leading to Microsoft's era of
Acquisitions he started off relatively
small with Mojang in 2014 for two and a
half billion dollars these are the guys
behind Microsoft but it didn't take him
long to scale up
in 2016 Microsoft would go ahead and buy
LinkedIn for 26.2 billion dollars he
followed us up with GitHub for seven and
a half billion dollars Cinemax media
also for seven and a half billion
dollars nuanced Communications for 19.7
billion dollars Activision Blizzard for
68.7 billion dollars and of course 10
billion in the chat GPT those are just a
few of Microsoft's most notable
Investments and Acquisitions here is a
full list of all of Microsoft's known
purchases
this isn't stark contrast to every other
Tech Giant Apple for example just avoids
high profile Acquisitions altogether
their last big purchase was Beats and
that was almost 10 years ago Google on
the other hand does do a crap ton of
Acquisitions but almost all of them are
in the tens of millions or hundreds of
millions they're not in the billions or
tens of billions they clearly prefer to
play an active role in building up
Brands as opposed to buying out
established businesses the only other
tech company that has engaged in such
massive deals is Facebook but there's a
key difference between Facebook's
purchases and Microsoft purchases
Facebook buys products to integrate into
their own ecosystem Microsoft buys
companies as passive Investments and it
keeps them as separate from their
original business as possible and if you
don't believe me check this out it's
been seven years since Microsoft
acquired LinkedIn but to this day there
is no sign in with Microsoft or Outlook
option though there is a sign in with
Google or Apple option the same thing
can be said about GitHub to create a
GitHub account you have to do it the
old-fashioned way by entering any email
address you can't just log in with
Microsoft
that's not just signing in either users
of these Services wouldn't even know
that these companies are owned by
Microsoft unless they were explicitly
told
this goes much deeper than just
superficial things as well if you ask
the CEOs of these acquired companies
they have nothing but good things to say
about Microsoft Microsoft has not
forgotten why we did the deal in the
first place and what the important
pillars of the deal are the first and
the foremost principle is to put
developers first and that is what we do
every day in stark contrast all of
whatsapp's and Instagram's Founders have
left Facebook on negative terms clearly
Microsoft isn't not just acquiring a
bunch of companies for a bunch of money
they're also maintaining them in the
right way
in the beginning of this video we talked
about how Microsoft is the only Tech
Giant that hasn't created a
revolutionary product in the past 10 to
20 years but they're also the only Tech
Giant that isn't dependent on one
revolutionary product
to this day over 50 percent of all of
Google's revenue comes from Google
search over 50 percent of Apple's
Revenue comes from the iPhone the only
reason Amazon is even profitable is
because of AWS and the entire business
of meta can be summed up by Facebook
WhatsApp and Instagram Microsoft on the
other hand isn't tied down by one or
even a handful of products they are
truly a diversified business with
hundreds and hundreds of products each
operating on Independent terms before
the sentiment around Microsoft was that
they were able to transition from being
a consumer business to being an
Enterprise business but this doesn't
tell the full story as they have since
transitioned from being an Enterprise
business to being a full-on holding
company
and that is the state of Microsoft today
and why they're able to get away without
innovating themselves are you a fan of
the new Microsoft comment that down
below also drop a like if you would like
to see more videos about the evolution
of various tech companies and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community suggest everybody ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
thank you